i was definitely about to do the halo
theme within jake's airplane it's
amazing oh wait let's let's freestyle
[Laughter]
[Music]
cocaine guys we just made a mumford and
sun song yeah we did that's i think the
exact way today
guys welcome to the bump and stomp after
hours podcast thanks for being here
thanks for joining us we hope your day
is going well and uh well welcome
everybody we're bumping we're starting
yourself who do we have today you're
wrong this is the youngest podcast ever
okay
so we have jonah dean and fenner dean i
feel like he wants to get right into it
so i'm not going to stop this what do
you want i'm just saying it's the
youngest podcast of all time there's
never been a podcast younger than this
except for you you out you kind of slide
the scales back in there i i bring the
average back up yep
thanks man i appreciate that
yeah starting from what is this the left
we got jonah who is should we do like
name birth year name birthday seriously
let's do that my name is jonah yeah and
i was born in the year of 1999. 99
i hear now when people walk into bars
when they check your id they just have
to look if it's the year 2000. yeah
making it easy that's it
yeah it is it's super easy to remember
my age too because i just it's for half
the year it's the year
that it is is my age whoa and then for
the second half of me i never thought of
that because i always forget how old i
am how old are you yeah well my name is
dean and i was born in 1997.
so
97 not too far off but i do forget often
how old i am
25 i think so
i think that's a good year 25. better
that's a good year i'm sorry
my name is defender thomas lemmons rock
cliff wow don't give out your full name
june 19th 19th
oh they don't have these canadians yeah
we don't we don't have a social what is
it you guys have social security number
yeah
we're incredibly insecure in canada we
don't have any social security you guys
don't have government numbers we have
social insurance numbers okay you guys
leave your doors unlocked we
legitimately do yeah anyways what year
were you born 1945 june 19th 1995.95
that's my sister he's 95.
that's great and everyone everyone just
look at
now you look at me so what do you got
i'm jake watson for those of you who
haven't met me on the internet i was
born in 1986
86 what
you're so old you're so old man what was
it like when everything was black and
white
it was crazy were there dinosaurs in
your neighborhood yeah so we were on the
classic debate of what what how to
define the generations um i think
millennials grew up before the internet
or like the internet came along
as they came up with it sort of yeah
but there was internet when you were a
kid yeah there well there was internet
but again i was born in 86 so by the
time i was 10 years old by the time we
got a personal computer in our house
and then it had the 56k dial up and so
it wasn't like he really like internet
wasn't really as
prolific you know obviously so
um
but then i think
the defining feature for the generations
would be you know everyone who grew up
with the internet just being a
in existence well yeah so when i was 10
years old that would have been when the
iphone came out
so that's
yeah so i was already in college yeah
that's the whoa you were in college when
i was 10 years old yes so
i went i started college in 0-4
dude yeah i was four so you would be jen
i was four or five yeah four and
oh four it means i was either four or
five depending on the time of the year
so that would make you gen x like the
very end of gen x maybe yeah like my
sister my i was the youngest of four so
they were kind of my sister was born in
78.
so they're kind of like that and then i
don't know if millennials are gen x or
millennials if there's a defining factor
there i think millennials are after gen
x so but before gen z yeah so we're just
watching we were talking about this the
other day because you're technically a
millennial yeah i'm like on the cusp
though technically i'm just in that
weird gray area what what happens here's
the here's the main question i'm trying
to get to what happens after gen z
right these what are you called
is that the death
yeah i don't think what happened
oh is that what you guys use for z yeah
we don't say z we said zed oh okay we
don't have social security numbers we
say zed could we do what could we we
could do symbols jen what seriously is
there is there have one is there a thing
for this because that would be what my
children are
it's gonna be like
i think they would still
uh maybe they're not z i hear people
throw around igen which i don't know
igen is like brought to you but it's
more about moniker i don't think it's
like an official generation well also
they're not just going by letters this
whole time yeah because technically
millennials are wise so it doesn't
doesn't this just mean that we start
back at a again well but who because
there's 26 generations ago we don't need
to worry about those guys we can start
back at a we're not going to confuse
anybody i think in general we tend to
like create far too minuscule categories
because if you look at it in a macro
sense like the fact that we've come up
with all these generations in the last
like 50 years we're just like freaking
out we're just like oh why
50 generations in the last 50 years
that's the thing is we start with
x i think like before that's the baby
boomers so like there's something
like that
my generation is the double boom
the double boom yeah we're the boom boom
boom because we're the boomers kids but
you're the dip after at least in terms
of actually having kids like you guys
are the big dip when to invest because i
thought you guys were the big dip
we might even be a bigger dip i think
every generation is pretty big different
i think every generation is dipping
lower than the last one yeah but the
baby boomers they just
they were going at it man or no the the
parents of the baby boomers were going
at it which they would have been the
greatest generation right yes that would
be the world war ii generation and then
who are the people the they're the
people who lived through all of the
worst things ever my grandmother because
now is really great too
this is our last podcast
we're pretty good right now
but the pandemic was the first thing
that was the first thing oh god i had to
your
do
will be that's basically their first
thing
yeah i guess so right yeah
yeah i guess well i mean we're on track
right
pandemic
and then we're gonna have it go ahead
depression we'll go through the
depression and then we'll have a giant
world war yeah and then things will be
great again and they're going to play
this back in 20 years
he knew dean was a prophet dean was a
prophet how did he know
there have been many things uh foreseen
on this podcast remember you've you
literally called the i called out niko's
broken collar bone oh something special
happens when you get in this room did
anyone want to call out wren's thumb i
don't want to call that ren broke his
thumb
riding into a rail on a one wheel dude
son of a dungeon curse every time
filming starts
yes so yes this is now a it's a
consistent there's a there's a trackable
factor here every time we do green
screen photography for son of a dungeon
somebody breaks a bone
i don't know why it is
yeah now that i think it's consistent
yeah i think that the strategy moving
forward if i
can be so bold is actually
uh and i know i have no say in this at
all but
i think before we start next season yeah
we gotta just take someone you know
someone who hasn't broken a bone yet we
didn't break their bones
we just free we have a blood sugar yeah
the bone break somebody on the crew
though like somebody who's like
unimportant the greatest
we'll call it the great jonah you for
instance listen man if it saves the rest
of us i'll take that out yeah somebody
open studio now somebody up in studio
three we break their bomb yeah they'll
be fine
in studio four yeah you might
yeah on a one wheel that that's also
true it has to be on some kind of eevee
electric
wheels mountain bike
something along those lines yeah so how
small of a bone we talking because like
can we get away with like a pinky or i
don't think you want to break that
because there's no way to like cast it
so you actually don't want it yeah
that's what it means it doesn't bend
okay oh did you break your pinky dude
it's that's as much as it bends it's
really gross wait a second that's about
as much of my bend i don't know you can
probably bend it back though straight
like that oh okay that's all it does i
was trying to question whether or not he
actually broke yeah
we'll get to the bottom of this
hold on we'll let the experts get to the
bottom of this yeah i think that like
you know just an arm or a leg or
something like that arm or a leg well
those are easy to like those are easy
fixes those are easy fixes they're big
you know it's got to be a it's got to be
like a nice clean fracture though you
know like we can't no shards yeah we
want a nice clean surgery have all the
breaks been surgery induced like they
like yeah surgery is definitely not
extreme
break yeah
because ren got collarbone surgery right
yeah but nico didn't did he could do he
just got it
i thought threw him through a wall i
couldn't tell yeah i'm not a
physiological surgeon so
yeah i don't know i don't know anyways
do we have bad bone break stories on the
couch has have we
been damaged
i've never broken a bone you've never
broken a bone i actually do think i
broke my foot like one of my toe bones
and i didn't do anything about it and
now it just doesn't like
my the
front joint doesn't even move
hey everyone um jake here again and i
still haven't left the farm uh you see
when i got here i i ran out of money and
then um i wasn't able to leave so now
i've just been uploading stock images
and uh stock b-roll that i've been
capturing myself onto story blocks for
other people to use hopefully as a way
to generate enough money to get out of
this place um because if you if you saw
the last integration that i did
i showed up at this farm i didn't know
about uh things like uh today's sponsor
story blocks and how you don't actually
need to travel to get high quality 4k
b-roll why well it's actually really
simple they have a virtually unlimited
library of high quality 4k b-roll
incredibly robust and beautiful images
audio assets motion graphics after
effects templates and more and you can
get all of it
royalty-free to use in whatever projects
you want
through their unlimited all-access plan
had i known that that would have saved
me a lot of time and money and you know
it's always good to do that when you're
in a creative process then you can put
more time into your timeline into your
project into the quality of that project
and not have to blow your video budget
coming out to a farm
and you know what the funniest thing is
is we use storyblocks every day at
corridor and i could have just asked one
of the other guys to say hey i need some
farm b-roll for a video project i'm
working on where should i get it and
they would have said yo go to
storyblocks and i would have said how do
i get there and they would have said
click the link in the description below
or go to storyblocks.comcast
and you can get everything you need uh
anyways
let's get back to the podcast
it's like fused so that's it like having
perfect bones dean yeah
uh well you know wren has weak baby
bones he's got babies he's got weak baby
bones yeah and he i mean he's very clear
about that he has a great story about
trying to when he was a kid trying to
pick up the book off the top shelf at a
library and it just broke his wrist
broken like 14 bones the first kid to
injure himself studying like yeah he was
studying so hard dude but yeah if you've
done an era before doctors he would have
died a long time ago
i think he also did karate and tried to
karate chop the kid and broke a bone
i didn't realize it really was that he
just has pretty brittle bones
wow well he needs to stop breaking it it
might it's it's either that he has
brittle bones or that ren is like a
daredevil yeah i mean he does a sign of
a life well-lived he's got soft bones
but that guy takes
i mean
brent's wife is like i always say this
his wife is like a
like the wives of the like test pilots
or
like the uh astronauts right like she's
just sitting at home waiting for the
call yeah you know
my uh my mom was a nurse actually in the
same way because friend's wife is a
nurse and like she would always downplay
my injuries because she was a nurse
she's probably listening to this like i
love you
i appreciate you but like i will
remember like i would get stupid injured
and she would just be like oh it'll be
fine like she just knew because she
didn't know you know and like i broke my
arm snowboarding at my friend's house
and
i sat at my friend's kitchen table for
like an hour and a half because my mom
was like not rushed to get there no they
like told they told like
she asked over the phone she's like yeah
so like what's the arm look like they
like described it she's like yeah that's
a green stick for actor like he's
totally fine all right i'm gonna finish
my shift and then i'll come oh my god
i'm just sitting there like by the way
we do 12-hour shifts
yeah exactly like they're so hardcore it
turned out it turned out all right
everything works in fact i did just
recommend that we should break someone
else's bones so clearly i'm a really
well adjusted person how do we want to
go about this
let's talk about something practical in
practice they can't know what's gonna
happen okay they can't no no we'll have
them sign a waiver reward like in fact
we'll have them
we'll put the waiver down we'll put a
nice wooden table okay
and then we'll have them reach out and
they'll sign the waiver and then as they
sign the waiver as soon as the pen comes
off the paper yeah a mechanism will drop
such as
their forearm guillotines and seriously
this is how we rebuild the gears we do
have the blade we'll bri we'll
we'll
make the blade so it's not yeah just
watch it and then just
make it safe yeah make it safe we don't
want to hurt okay we'll set up two
wooden tables
with a gap in the middle oh wow and then
they'll have to slide their arm across
the gap
and then
they'll be blindfolded of course
and then they'll sign and then as soon
as that pen comes off
boom so it's just random it's just
whoever decided well you're honestly in
a way you're punishing like the person
who's
like most ahead of the curve on like oh
i'm going to get ahead go get her sign
this waiver
i feel like maybe we should be the last
maybe
random i think that maybe it's a lottery
system in the sense that like
we make it public knowledge that
someone's going to break their arm
and then though yeah and then we go if
you're willing like let us know and we
have like a list and then we just roll a
dice whatever it says we have a week
how do we randomly what if we do this in
the old
and we vet out like the miscreates of
the group you know
the the the drifters and the skulkers
yeah and we find we find them what what
i mean what label somebody a miscreant i
don't know when i walked in the corner
jake was hanging out by a dumpster so
yeah
you would be on this one
i might be on the list i'm not look i'm
not absolved of anything here i i might
be on that list i think tattoos put you
on tattoos yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm clean but you know i wanna hear you
my my friend's dad i was up north uh for
the fourth of july and my friend's dad
was like kind of drunk and he was like
yeah i don't don't trust anything this
guy says he's got tattoos
for sure man
yeah
he's a great guy he's a legend
good old dave love that guy yeah i love
that guy shout out to you dave
shut up dave
but anyway back to breaking people's
arms
right so that's how we're going to go
about it um maybe we'll let the
commenters decide yeah they can figure
who do you guys want to see
break their forearm green light paige
all the money that's worth those points
will go to that person's medical bill oh
man here we go and whatever's left over
they get to keep i forgot there's
somebody bills
oh yeah
have you ever heard about the privatized
health care system we can talk about it
on a different body that's a different
body we can go into that if you guys
want to there are arguments on both
sides yeah i'm not going to say where i
stand but i'll give you the arguments
yeah
well speaking of son of a dungeon
wait first though i want to talk about
this thor ragnarok
oh so don't know me yeah jonah and
fenner went to see it last night i don't
know if you've seen it
okay so but i snapped a little picture
and in the credits i saw a name
and that name was fenner rockcliff
they didn't do the full name what no
they didn't what they didn't do no well
first then last i know but i wanted that
middle name
what's your middle name thomas
and so social security
labeled shots yeah what does that mean i
worked on shots i'm not a canadian
fender but my great grandfather was oh
well he was born in rainy river
which is anyways yeah you guys like
northern norway we'll go into that after
this yeah yeah i want to hear about the
northeast he knew the real thor
probably the real historical photo yeah
freaking odinson up there um yeah it was
cool uh i worked on the compositing team
at weta on it so
vfx credits are always super weird
because like some of the studios there
they had like compositing credits but
then what has just said shots for
whatever reason so i think that's cool
it's kind of cool yeah
um it's more vague and vague it's cool
yeah yeah so yeah man it was such a cool
project to work on i uh
yeah loved it it's probably one of my
favorite projects i've ever done it was
extremely dinner almost
until the movie was done but yeah i came
here yeah it was like yeah i had uh i
had to call jake and be like dude they
like
they don't want me to leave because like
the project because of covid like so
many projects got delayed and i was
supposed to be wrapped um by the time my
what a contract ended but
the project pushed and then my contract
was ending and so they were like hey can
you stay and i was like no i'm
going to corridor sorry i got another
gig yeah are you oh sorry i was just are
you allowed to talk about the shots that
you worked on or uh i i don't know i
actually don't i don't i think it's i
think uh the movies
so when he's out and you don't work
there anymore when you look at the movie
with the good shots those are the ones
that fender did there you go just when
you see a shot that's real tasty all
those shots of chris hemsworth looking
even beefier than the before that's all
thinner you can't break those bones they
actually mod yeah they instead of photo
scanner
yeah exactly thank you yeah they modeled
chris's body off of fenner this is the
greatest compliment i've ever received
in my entire life dude
because that guy's crazy shredded man
he's just like consistently through
every movie gotten more and more jacked
like you were saying his stunt double
wrote like some like yeah i don't have
yeah he basically one of his stunt team
was in preparation for this movie was
interviewed kind of like spoke out
basically saying like i love chris
hemsworth but what he's putting me
through is like genuinely difficult
because he's getting so huge
that my job to keep up with his frame is
like difficult and they don't have that
same resources
but i can just kind of see it because
i'm sure chris hemsworth has like the
biggest team behind him that's like
personal training whatever it is yeah
his own company or whatever but uh you
know they put him on his diet he's got
personal chefs he's got diet diets
[Music]
yeah man it's i mean i'm sure it's
probably
i would imagine a little bit harder for
his
stunt performer to have the same access
to all that stuff oh yeah but great
movie though i dude i loved it like
i think people have a lot of marvel
burnout and so i went in with super low
expectations because i was feeling that
way like i haven't loved a lot of the
recent marvel stuff
so i think that was the best way to go
into it i was just like whatever and
then i was like this is great i agree
that is the
best way to go into any like modern big
blockbuster superhero movie whatever
it's like just and this sounds awful but
just like lower your expectations and
you'll have a great time yeah which
sucks kind of but also it was awesome
because the thing is the movies are
still
amazing visual feasts they're like have
you know a-list actors and crazy action
and
they're fun sound design sound design
gets so overlooked dude they're so
overlooked jake there's a sickest sound
design moment where they go from full on
like the adobe atmos stereo just to all
of a sudden it goes to mono in theater
really and it's you're just like
what just happened yeah it's so cool
people don't like think about it yeah
but if there's
so much work and design and style and
art that goes into it and you're just
you sit down and you're like oh the
visuals individuals and the actor and
the actresses and but meanwhile the
entire time there's like this
perfectly leveled
balanced
orchestra
going on behind you music design
elements yeah all that stuff there's
actually it's so crunchy and crispy when
you're in the theater yeah
to detour into uh dune there's an
amazing
uh documentary that the warner brothers
youtube channel put out about the sound
design of dune
and it was they went all out they like
went out to the desert and were
for the thumpers which uh have you seen
the movie where i've seen parts of it i
kept trying to watch it on hbo max and
it kept it would start and then give me
like three minutes
and i did that for the basically the
first act the perfect cinematic
experience
that made me feel better about
quarterdigital.com
i'll just put it that way
but
the thing is universal these things
called thumpers in the movie which is
how they attract the the giant worms
and like they actually went out to death
valley just to like slam these things on
the ground and record it in the same way
awesome because the whole movie is like
uh like the sound is the main like kind
of what you're saying is like the sound
is the main character like the score and
the sound design and i think even han
zimmer almost was like i'm just gonna do
the sound design for the movie because
the score is like so embedded in
this like sonic landscape of that that's
so good man and uh yeah i think it is
definitely like an underrated thing but
these marvel movies i mean also have i
love old movies i love watching old
movies um
but the sound design is so shrill yeah
on most of them you find one that has
good sound design and it's it's a keeper
man yeah yeah and some some of them were
able to pull it off and and i know that
there's been remasterings and things
like that over time but
yeah um yeah that's the one drawback
they should do like a beatles
you know that uh what was it love the
beatles album where they remastered all
the songs in stereo they should do
something like that for a bunch of
classics we um we actually just reviewed
the first like
the pun for punch witcher short with
sound design today yes dude like there
were some shots in that was like i don't
know if this works like because it's all
you know rubber foam weapons and stuff
but i think we need you to do two two
more shots yeah
i was like i feel like those rings
should be glowing
yeah or there's one shot where there's
no rings on his fingers yeah that's okay
we can do those okay those aren't those
ones aren't crazy and then there's one
sorry i'm just going to finish this
there's one where there's a halberd and
the halberd is bent i know you just need
to cut it and then move it yeah track it
just
but yeah but they sound great what i was
gonna say is those weapons like that was
the biggest thing that stood out for me
in our previous cuts without sound
is
they feel foamy because there is yeah
there's the halberd that's a bit you
know limp yeah um
but what kind of helps sell that is like
seeing the what like the weapon drops
and then there's like a metal clang
sound yeah and it helps you it helps
that believable oh a thousand percent it
was the same thing when i'm working on
thor i remember watching a rough cut of
it and i was like
oh i don't know if this like fight
sequence works at all and then you see
it in the movie with the sound design
there's like lightning cracks and yeah
because so much of it is energy
and you're like this is awesome
i can't imagine for those actors
i mean at this point it's like they're
basically in like the george lucas
prequels like just standing on a blue
screen
waving their hands around being like i
guess this will look cool later
especially i mean to multiverse of
madness doctor strange and and uh
scarlet witch
all of what they're doing is just waving
their hands around and making like weird
shapes the behind the scenes looks so
goofy because it's just someone doing
this like on a blue screen you're like
what is this that's like honestly and
this sound like obviously they're
getting paid millions of dollars
whatever but that's
where acting is like they they're
professionals you know they're like
they're they're at work doing those
movies and uh yeah big respect to them
yeah you gotta believe it yourself yeah
that's that's rule number one i mean
we're filming all week and
we're filming in front of this giant
green screen but
you have to take that moment before each
take and just go okay i'm not here
anymore i am in the place that we've
created in our minds and i am only there
and just and and it can be hard to do
but uh
it's it's worth it when you can
when you can do that and then you know
whether it's uh
the post or whether it's additional
footage and then that you know whether
it's things off screen makes the
universe feel bigger and then sound
design comes in and then that makes the
universe feel more complete and then all
of a sudden it starts to take on this
totally different picture than just the
raw footage yeah this is it oh sorry go
ahead does it feel you know because we
were talking about how dr strange you're
just in standing in front of a green
screen you are standing in front of a
green screen but does it help your
performance to be able to look across
and see that immersive world behind you
because i feel like
that's huh wow it's a great question
mind me um because that's a little
different right you you get that real
world reference and that's different
than a volume where it is really behind
you it's like kind of the perfect medium
does that affect your performance how
does that affect your body it definitely
does and it definitely helps uh to see
the
the environment that you're in but
also sometimes it's it's more
useful for just understanding where
things are spatially and then
once you understand okay that thing that
we talked about is there and that thing
that we talked about is there
then i my technique is to i kind of just
turn away from the screen at that point
once i understand where everything is
spatially because then i can just see it
you know i can just see it in my head
and i go okay
um
that's there that's there and then you
you just you just act as if it's there
um it's weird it's it's kind of you have
to separate your
your
normal sense of um
being in normal reality
which is we're constantly like trying to
grasp okay what read the room who's
doing this who's doing that what's
somebody saying to you what's what are
the objects maybe you're driving down
the road you know you gotta we're so
honed in on focusing on what our actual
reality is
when you
consciously try to break that
that can
it just takes a little getting used to
yeah yeah i
i thought about i talked to clint once
he said he took this acting class
which was crazy and they were like
pretending to be animals and stuff yeah
and uh people might remember the the
lion king video where he was doing all
the mocap for the animals
and like
clint commits 1 000 to that kind of
stuff and um
i just
after seeing that what you're saying
right now i like i'm like i kind of want
to take an acting class just like feel
it out you know because we just sit
behind our desks all day and we get like
limp little editor's wrists
yeah
yeah it's good to do it helps you
understand uh
what
you're looking for when you're filming
or directing something and then on the
other side my being a producer primarily
um
it helps me act better because i can
i know what i know what the crew is
looking for too
you know and so i just think
understanding the more well-rounded you
are
the better the better you'll be as an
artist i think completely you know um
that reminds me of a conversation i was
having with mark today um i don't want
to speak for him but like i was so
curious about how he performs because
like you're saying like as creators you
sometimes you're a little behind and
that's markiplier for people that's
markiplier
on that first name
i'm sorry yeah um
i was like hey man
you've been marketing the intern yeah
you've been such a joy to shoot with
like how do you how do you improv how do
you what is your process
and like
because i'm i'm really obsessed with
that like to be able to he is
so on all the time every take is good in
a different way and i'm not saying that
we don't have that he's a phenomenal
actor yeah yeah and i was like how do
you do it and he he took improv classes
to your point like he took it seriously
man like he loves yeah he loves the
performance part of it and that was
actually really cool he was like
talking about how he wants to bring like
an improv teacher to corridor yeah and
like how fun would that be if you took a
day off
i would love that yeah man i remember um
i'm sorry well i was just gonna say i
think jordan allen and matt karen's both
come from an acting background and uh i
know i think both of them have done
improv
and uh yeah they have that same muscle
which is like you just go with it yeah
it's the yes and like mentality
yeah and you gotta be
you gotta be willing to get weird with
it you know oh yeah and
that's just how it is um
clint used to have these parties
this is the stupidest la thing ever i'm
sorry but
it's kind of funny it's a funny story he
used to have these parties um
and
we would do
improv
at the parties so everyone would be
sitting around and then
you know a few people would get in the
middle
and then there'd be a prompt and then
you had to act it out and it was just
kind of this funny
show that the group would sort of
collectively put on for everyone else it
was really fun
yeah and it's like it's such a like to
to go see improv is one thing sometimes
it can be very hard to watch but like
doing it with your friends or whiskey
helps
[Laughter]
but like doing with your friends or
uh even like using it i mean honestly
son of a dungeon like
d and d is kind of a game of improv in a
lot of ways and you guys are using that
as a as a uh jumping off point for like
telling stories right yeah and it's just
it's such a generative process because
it's
you're committing to the collaborative
environment it's not like
like the the requirement is that you
lose your ego the requirement is that
you're like okay i'll throw out my idea
but then i'm going to jump on somebody
else's idea and it's like you're not
like um no i really want to do this
because if you're sitting in the middle
of the sketch and everybody's like oh
it's a hospital and you're like no it's
uh yeah we're at the police station
right exactly yes yes that's that's one
of the best most fun things about it um
and i and
obviously there's that fall offline
which is pretty clear you know when you
get when you get too deep into improv or
when you get too deep into d d culture
the fall off can be really hard and then
there's sort of the subculture
underneath it that's really obsessed
with that the gameplay mechanics and the
other elements and stuff but yeah
generally even people who are really
into the subculture if you can
keep the general audience entertained
with it then they're gonna like that too
so yeah that's what we try to do with
that show is go more for in in season
two we're going even harder in that
direction like we don't need to know how
they level up nobody cares i mean some
people care but it doesn't matter the
people that care they probably know they
understand it right yeah it it it's
it doesn't really matter you know like
we knew that and that helped drive the
story but once it's not like you need to
know what was in the script versus what
was improvised all you need to know is
what was in the four frames that you saw
and was it connected to the other parts
and was that entertaining so we're just
trying to focus on that um and i think
it's better this year than it was last
year on that alone but then there's all
these other elements that
are gonna come through i mean obviously
the visual effects
uh the more complete music and
composition
uh
hopefully we can send it off to kevin to
do mastering
for the sound design
um and then there's nine episodes deeper
story um i think more com we were more
comfortable as players too and not just
in character but also in understanding
okay
when the editors cut this together
this is going to be more efficient for
me to say what i'm doing like this
versus to for me to say what i'm doing
like that
um
and so all of those things i think
are coming together in season two so
hopefully people like it um i'm super
excited for it i am too i am really
excited for it if if it can drive more
subs and people really like it then
we'll keep the show going and and it'll
be it'll be awesome and that's what i
what i hope happens
and maybe we'll get a freaking
led wall
set up
mini volume
we need more space guys yeah
how's the space problem been honestly
we're getting a lot of a lot of people
in here man a lot of people but
it's good man you know i like
i'll always be pushing the bunk desks
once we get too many people you just put
another desk on top and the other person
sits on your shoulders that's efficient
man and then you're good
and then do we have some kind of
elevator system that brings them up now
they just hop on your shoulders oh they
just hop on your shoulder okay right
exactly do you need a new chair do i
need a new chair yeah it is like he just
needs a friend to sit on would you like
a new chair it is like the perfect chair
for
my height like the arm rests these are
the same model give me the well i mean
you know it works i think you should get
a new chair
it you know if that's in the cards man
the cards you know
if you behave yourself
you know if you sacrifice a bone or two
yeah you want if you sacrifice see this
is the thing with the bones it's like
you could
like i think a better system is a reward
system
if somebody volunteers up their bone
they get something nice you know yeah
get something real nice yeah you know
new lens
you know
get a subscription to houdini or
something you know
subscription to quarter digital quarter
digits
are you um are you
trying to expand are we trying to break
the wall into that space start taking
over this whole block what's your vision
man you seem like you have a vision
i would love to stay in this building um
now
stress level zero has three other units
in this building there's only six total
and then there's one other one um
so
you know i don't want to
cause any rifts or anything um
we love this building we have a ton of
history here
so obviously that would be our first
option
we got closets man we could put some
people in there oh and then like three
people everyone's kind of
situated there
where they live
based on
you know this location being here so
if we went somewhere else
probably wouldn't want to go too far um
but it's just then this the cost factor
comes up you know i mean we still rent
this building
we we we've been a company for 12 years
and
we
don't have we still rent our bill now a
lot of companies do that but it's for
like specific purposes whereas this one
we just haven't bought a building
because they're so damn expensive
and so it's it is a hindering factor i
think there's a lot of benefits to being
where we are
but one of the hindering factors is just
simply you know if we were literally
anywhere else in the country other than
chicago or new york
we could have
10 000 square feet of studio space
probably on 10 acres yeah and you can
film whatever backlots
sets
randomly we could also but
you wouldn't have you know oh hey i'm
just gonna be in town can i come on be
on vfx artists react and can oh can you
just guys want to come and there's so
there's a trade-off um but we definitely
i'm feeling the pinch
spatially i'm feeling the pinch we could
you know there's abandoned parts of la
we could set up like a corridor
encampment i think
out there that'll run the yeah
and like we could just here's a wacky
idea do you think we could pay a bunch
of homeless people to like take over a
certain area and then claim clear it out
for us dominance breaks and bones for us
yeah like a city that no this is our
space now to be employing people yeah
giving people jobs
unfortunately the developer
world is
too racketed in to the city government
so that would never happen but for other
reasons too but yeah
for other reasons too sure
yeah i think that it would be really
cool to have a bigger space like i think
that
one of the things we run into is when
when there's like one thing happening in
the studio it's super productive but
when there's like multiple things
happening
except you just start you just don't
have the floor space because i mean if
we had multiple different
units where we could set up different
stages on each unit yeah then we could
have one that's a volume we could have
one that's son of a dungeon we could
have one that's vfx artist react i mean
those could just be set up yeah yeah and
then you could
you could just use them dude it's so
funny we used to we were down here and
then we're like we need quiet space so
we opened up studio three
and then right now it's three or three
it's never quiet right because they're
filming things up there all day
days like that's quiet please we're
filming you guys guys
they have a giants
like tomorrow we're coming in and we're
like okay let's get in early yeah it's
like okay they're shooting this and then
we're gonna shoot right after in their
same setup and then they're shooting
downstairs it's just a con
stream i came into the room that i stay
at when i'm here and chase was in there
filming today
jason's in the bed wasn't he
oh hey chase
dude everybody's got a camera
everybody's filming something it's like
you want you want more space but
part of you
worries that it you lose some of that
charm you know
i thought that that's not true because i
thought that when we were
when we were in studio four i was like
we're gonna lose some of that like
newsroom kind of feel and it like we
just you
it fills it's infectious the amount of
space you get it will fill that space
you know what i mean i think there's
like a project timeline yeah yes i think
there's a big like
i don't know discussion to be had there
of like intentional growth versus just
like trying to chase that too right
because if you're like okay we just got
to expand and you expand then all of a
sudden it's like okay now we have to
fill this space rather than being like
okay we have filled this current space
we need more space
yeah it's a hard balance because you
kind of in some ways have to be
preemptive
to like stay on top of things but then
you can almost jump the gun in some ways
and then i think in when you're doing
that i think that's when you do lose a
bit of the magic yeah no absolutely yeah
growth for the sake of growth i don't
think is healthy for any sort of
just anything really like i think you
have to have very intentional growth
with any sort of especially creative
fields like
i think that's kind of honestly some of
the to go back to marvel some of the
marvel burnout i think we were seeing
like phase one was like 12 hours of
content and phase four is already at
like 58 or something yeah you know it
doesn't feel like it has any direction
yeah it's sort of the same amount of
magic has now been spread out to all
this content you know and yeah no i
totally i totally agree with you to me
that's
way more important than
anything else yeah especially in our
industry we're not just making shoes or
whatever where we go oh well people want
more shoes make more shoes yeah you know
we're making
these little stories and we're crafting
these little shows and they have
timelines and they have story and they
have
through lines and they
have there's novelty to them and we're
pushing the boundaries here we're
pushing the boundaries there
that to me is way more fun enjoyable and
makes it worth it than
you know just
like oh well
let's just produce more of this thing or
more of that thing
um yeah and a bigger team means more
right hierarchy you can very easily fall
into those pitfalls of going well you
know it made sense but now we'll for
i'll give you an example
punch for punch
we've got four episodes we think they're
really good
the whole idea behind that process was
to submit that to netflix with the hope
that they pick it up for an actual run
on the platform
now if they pick it up for a run on the
platform
smallest case scenario they're going to
buy 12 they've already bought four so
then they buy eight more
so now you go and even if they tripled
the budget from what it was well okay so
now
you've dedicated team
that's just doing that show
for
what basically a year is basically how
long it would take to produce that and
then now
so now you have
what
you know
five more full-time people four more
full-time people that are just working
on that show and then
and so you have to pick you have to pick
where you want to put your creative
points because if you just
i'm not saying we we won't do that but
at the same time there's the
consideration of saying okay well is
that
what we want
to do is that what we want to do is that
whatever we want to put or would it be
would it be more interesting to say well
what what are what are some of these
other things that
that we can do
you know what when like yeah what can we
do another boss town dynamics can we do
another
you know have we done one of those in a
while we i mean yeah so the idea of like
refinement versus expansion yeah do you
stick with what you're doing and make it
like the best version of itself or do
you try to branch out and create more
and potentially pick up
new viewership new audiences
that sort of thing and just do more
versus doing less but doing it better
yeah you know original pitfall on
corridor was we
literally had no repetition it was there
was none it was
i remember
this
making
i don't know pic pick a video dubstep
guns whatever one of these old videos
that did really well at the time
and then we wouldn't touch them again
because we'd go oh well that video did
great we don't we already did that
concept
and and we were so
focused on just the newest craziest idea
we could do we had no concept of
well you
it's kind of hard to do that maybe you
want to do another one yeah and and it
picks up some traction and gain some
momentum and and repeat the process so
you can continue you know just having
having a profession
um so that was something we had to learn
uh
but i also have always been very adverse
to the opposite problem which is just
you know
formulating making everything formulaic
and then yeah i think that's squeezing
out that creativity like in the us i
think that's the reason we always lean
towards that because it's it's so easy
to quantify that like okay we grew this
much and it you know we hired these
people
and this much profit and all that stuff
almost like we don't even question it
yeah but we question its value what
fener saying is like the value that
again is provided to us creatively when
you do those projects to the audience
and in their like emotional attachment
to it it's like that stuff
you that's not you can't put that on a
spreadsheet you can't like you know what
i mean so
it's such a but like you're saying it is
it has to be a balance because it can't
just be like totally
right you know it's own everything you
got to make it for yourself
but other people have to like it yeah
exactly
yeah if it's too niche you can't keep
doing it
right yeah
it's a it's such a hard balance to
strike too of just being like
okay this is super fulfilling for myself
but people actually do want to watch
this like right you have to find that
balance and that's like
i don't know it's been a really
interesting challenge with coming here
as well just like because it's my first
time doing like content creation that's
going into the world kind of and that's
i don't know it's really cool
really like more of you is on the line
right yeah totally man it's like you
know with like
with thor like uh natalie was saying
she was like oh i'm sorry i said
like mean things about it i was like
it's not my movie
i don't mind like could you yeah it's
like it's you know
you always have that kind of get out of
jail free card you're like that's not my
movie but if it's like a project a
corridor you're like well that's mine
like i'm so i put that baby out into the
universe and that's that will always be
more fulfilling than being one of even
if you're the director one of a thousand
names is like
you know peter just made this amazing
short film yeah you got to talk about
scooty though and
like i want to bring that to that yeah
yeah yeah you know that's him yeah go
watch scooty it's so good stop this and
go but then come come back 19 minutes
play it in the in the corner
i've re-watched scooty like probably
like five six times yeah yeah it's so
good score the score talk about sound
design the score yeah that's a i mean
that's a great example of like
he put time into that man that was three
years of effort and
it could have been something that was
like just super niche you know when you
hear the pitch for that you're like it's
a scooter that comes to life and they
like and you're like what it's still
pretty niche yeah right but it's like
anything but it had enough refinement
and enough love put into it over those
three years that it was created
something that was polished enough and
had enough mass appeal that it is very
like
i don't everything i've seen about it is
people love it i find it very universal
it's like a cute main character it's
like a it's like a
fun story like it's uh
yeah i think it's just it has like
specificity and universality i think
like
i mean another great example is ian
huber
who made his short film
dream dynamo dream yeah and um that like
that's 10 years right yeah
again it's like you look at that you're
like okay this looks like a hollywood
film
but this was one guy yeah which is
you know first of all like the appeal of
3d8 and
like getting into it this year has been
just like oh you can do whatever you
want yeah and i think in the future
we're gonna see a lot more
of these kinds of projects where it's
just somebody's like i'm gonna spend
years of my life on my own
to make
this tiny thing
but it is like so like you watch those
and it's like so distilled
in terms of like the vision and the art
that you're getting from it it's like
it's worth it is worth that you know 10x
totally passed uh you know marvel movie
or something you know because it's like
so yeah it's hard to compare it to a
marvel movie it's it's a different thing
yeah it's a different thing and i think
you have to look at it with a different
eye and appreciate it for what it is
because
yeah
there's
the cutting edge of using technology
that's available to you
obviously
time is a huge factor that's the one
thing you don't get back yeah um but if
you can do something that's
really eye-catching and novel and pushes
the art form further then you know
that's
that's a contribution to what
someone will do the next time yeah yeah
and it's also
it's a life well-lived like if you can
i feel you know that's how i feel it's
like if you could find something to do
all day that you like doing yeah you
know because it's like that's
you know you work a job that's eight
hours of your day that's most of your
life
uh it has to be
something that you enjoy and it you know
if you're you know we're so
super lucky lucky to be here and just
screwing around making fun stuff and
like if you
get to make something with your hands i
know we're clicking on mouses and stuff
but it's like we're making this stuff
with our hands
with ourselves baby hands
but um yeah there's you know
a lot of people out there even in
creative industries who are
you know
sitting behind a debt like i've i've had
that job you know where i'm just sitting
behind a desk somebody's telling me what
to do and it's like i'm
i was just happy to be like editing
videos but i was like this is
i'm just i'm a conduit for this other
person you know it's like i'm not in
this yeah it's product and john and i
were actually talking about this this
morning it's the concept of working with
people versus working for someone you
know yeah like working for people versus
working with people and like it was it
was super cool seeing love and thunder
and being like there's my name in the
credits
and there's like two thousand other
names like we literally couldn't even
find my name because
oh there it is like and it's like i'm
stoked man i was it was so rewarding
working on that project but i'm also
like
a lot of people did that like yeah so
whereas you know you see the the credits
for scooty and it's like
oh there cool or dude the stormtrooper
video in the batman video it's like yeah
here you go guys yeah batman video yeah
like stormtroopers way more fulfilling
than thor which sounds weird like thor
is so cool i'm so happy that i got to do
that
but also stormtroopers like that's kind
of you know the baby we put out there
and yeah the batman video has been taken
off
that's my second life man yeah yeah so
oh no take it off youtube yeah pulled
down oh i thought that yeah no way yeah
yeah the standalone cut that we put on
corridor yeah oh no wb
claimed it and then i submitted an
appeal and then they
and then they said no and then i
submitted a dispute and then they and
now it's been removed
and now we have to start a legal process
to get it back up online what's what's
the uh
we just have the results so so check
this out
they're claiming
that under the fair use doctrine
we don't have a claim of fair use
because
they're claiming not
the new batman trailer footage they're
claiming the 60s the audio only oh from
adam west's voice from the sixties
series you know what's up oh that's
they're saying they're saying because we
own that you guys didn't do enough
originality with it we we have a right
to demonetize this or take it down have
they ever heard a rap song in their life
right so i think that this has been kind
of an automated process because i
submitted the last dispute at 11
30 pm last friday
and within 30 minutes
it was manual takedown
now
tell me what lawyer
is working for wb
that was up
at 11
59
on a friday doing takedowns yeah there's
no way there's no [ __ ] way what also
sucks is adam's family like adam's
family reposted the video and they loved
it
it's like what like come on man
i'm missing the point yeah yeah so i
think we have to
pursue this and it'll be kind of our
first one where we actually
i think what's probably going to happen
is i'm going to submit the next dispute
and then that's actually going to go to
one of their lawyers and then one of
their lawyers is going to go oh this is
well that's how hollywood works is they
just they take you right up to the line
they're like we're going to take all the
money you have like they'll take you
right up the line but if it's a
ridiculous case
at the last like if you actually just
stand your ground they'll be like oh
yeah i guess guarantee some people watch
that video and we're like man i should
go check out the adam west series oh and
just only have their money how can we
not improve the market yeah like the
market for the original yeah no like
literally if it like at least in the
crew video the whole argument is like
we're gonna you know bring adam west
back yeah well the ai didn't watch that
video
i don't think the ai that wb has posing
as a manual person
watched that video yeah that's
ridiculous man so that's that's
something we got to do next week
um
and then oh there's one more thing i
wanted to talk about so mark had an idea
mark the intern
you guys know mark the intern
marquee player yeah
actually i guess he's gotta use one time
by accident you got very mad at me
markiplier i said markiplier and he said
no
he said
we don't do that jonah no and you're
like shut up interns
slapped him around made him fix the
water jokes there you go perfect
uh
he had an idea
we create
another channel he called it corridor
dump but
i called it i call it corridor crude
what about quarter craft yeah
we've talked about me and mark talked
about the crap
that's pretty good with two p's
oh
like french
hidden camera in the poop dungeon is
that
no that would be an invasion of privacy
you signed the waiver yeah they signed
the waiver get their arms broken
afterwards
that would definitely be a criminal
offense warner brothers would take that
video yeah
this is in poor taste so anyways the
idea behind this channel is uh anybody
on the crew who wants to make something
and upload it obviously outside of you
know
intentional dungeon intentional stuff
that's inappropriate or like political
topics things like that but anybody who
wants to make something creative
and put it on there is welcome to
there's no release schedule there's
nothing we we say to everybody hey look
this is just a channel as an outlet for
who's ever but and i think that would be
fun i mean you have those blender
renders you know
we've all got stupid ideas and
a lot of times
maybe we don't make them because there's
no outlet for them yeah right but what
if we just did that and then it was just
a
it was just there and available
yeah
i think there's
you know we'll have uh
matt will do covers of of toto songs i
think
you know with the whistle because
they're if you want to slide
dude there could be like
yeah because there's weird antics and
stuff that we get up to that never end
up on
anything but are filmed and it's like
that could just go up as like i don't
know i don't know
dude i don't even know what youtube i
don't know what youtube shorts are but
they feel like youtube they can be short
i think it's a great idea like i think
that
when mark and i were talking about it
like just
to be able to
work through things creatively and be
able to have an audience is really
important and like getting feedback is
really important yeah and
for the people like these young bucks
here on the couch who's the youngest
youngest guys ever the youngest guys
ever like you know we are privileged
there are literally no men younger than
these three men right here um youngest
man
we're super privileged to like have
inherited a massive audience yeah um and
that's like a really special experience
like living that first hand and
to then be able to have like a channel
where like you know
you can just release something that
you're passionate about that would be
huge that'd be really huge i think we
should do it and it also leads to like
experimentation more you know it's like
the pixar model it's just like you know
it's better to go
and try something new and not try it at
all even if it ends up weird you know
like quarter crap's a good name yeah i'm
going to nab that with the cms before
somebody takes off when this podcast
comes out so don't even try it i've
already already got you the warner
brothers exactly closing alarms so i
don't forget because what happened last
time we said we remember we said we were
going to do something before a podcast
came out and then it came out and we
hadn't done it yet it should be a like
we have the
yellow and black like flipped from the
corridor and quarter crew logos it
should just be a brown sea
oh no
just round it off brown yeah
crap
cold or crazy i like the idea that it's
just like inverted colors that'd be fun
it's kind of like the the b side yeah of
course i feel like the quarter crew and
corner are already inverted
so we invert these
are fine
um yeah man i i feel like there's
definitely stuff that we get up to that
should just be out there because some
stuff like it's it's such a fun job
because like every day you're probably
gonna laugh your ass off about something
yeah i'm gonna post oh sorry yeah it's
just and that stuff doesn't get out
there and it's like stuff that would be
funny to [ __ ] like literally today when
we were taking that thumbnail for
daniel's crew video we're all standing
around
praising this ball that's stuck to the
ceiling and like singing gregorian
chants like
that's like 15 second video just throw
it up like whatever yeah and like to to
that point you know i think there's a
vocal uh
group on the website that sometimes get
frustrated that the crew cuts are
smaller or shorter and like super valid
but i it's not that the stuff isn't good
like we there is the content there but
like when i'm crafting that story you
have to understand that like in order to
make it compelling and and interesting
like there is stuff that just doesn't
make sense for it to be in there even if
it's funny and like it'd be really fun
to just be able to release like two
minute videos that are just like yeah
just the goofs man like you know and
goofs are awesome like i want to put
them in there but if it negatively
affects like the meaning of the video
then it's difficult for me to justify
you you putting that in there having
people say these episodes are too short
is exactly what oh that's
that when they say that they mean the
episode is the perfect language they won
because because what it is is you you
you you you saw the video you loved it
you wanna you want another one no one
why does this charity have to end i
shouldn't yes what it is is that you
watch this like a mini video you were
you swept up in it and then it ended and
you're just realized i'm sitting here on
the toilet
in the poop in my
my bathroom right with myself take me
back
take me back to the escape land take me
back no no it's great um that's that's
what you want you you don't want to draw
it out to the point where no one's
saying that
you know you you always want to leave a
little something so that people come
back i've never looked at it that way
but thank you for giving me that
perspective but i'm i'm my harshest
critic so i just want everyone to be
happy right well you know so everyone
else will never happen yeah yeah it's a
bad way to live
yeah you can't try to make everybody
happy all the time it's a bad way to
live yeah but i hope everybody listening
to this podcast is happy with the
conversation the the vibes that we're
having so with that
dean's got the perfect vibes right now
you're just vibing out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
seemed to know what lay in store
lay in the store
towards the bed i kept on turning until
mama couldn't hold me anymore
[Music]
tried
[Music]
yeehaw
thank you very much so uh when do we
start the podcast
is that the pre-podcast have a great day
everybody